hi in this video we are going to talk
about the mallet a spurted shuttle
system as the name suggests it's again a
shuttle system which would shuttle
mallet and aspartate across the
mitochondrial membrane but let's put
this phenomenon in a physiological
context to understand the necessity of
this kind of shuttle system and how the
shuttle shuttle system actually operates
at a molecular level so we know that
glycolysis pathway takes place in the
cytoplasm where glucose is converted to
several intermediate and then ultimately
it girl give rise to pyruvate as the end
product now apart from pyruvate NADH is
produced and some amount of ATP is
produced as well the pyruvate would be
immediately channeled inside
mitochondria which can be used to
produce acetyl co a and thereby it would
go to the crib cycle of the TCA cycle
and the NADH which is produced in the
glycolysis pathway can be channeled into
the electron transport chain to generate
ATP but there is a fundamental problem
the NADH which is generated in the
cytoplasm by the process of glycolysis
cannot enter cannot enter the
mitochondria because the mitochondrial
inner membrane is totally impermeable to
NADH as a result a alternative pathway
is required it turns out their shuttle
system which are important for
transporting NADH into the mitochondrial
matrix such that it can enter the
electron transport chain and can
generate ATP so let's see how the
Mallett aspartate shuttle works now we
understand the context of it so the key
transporters of malok aspartate shuttle
are Mallett alpha keto butyrate
antiporter and
glutamate aspartate antiporter all these
names suggest these are anti Porter's
that means the transport direction is
different for two solutes one would be
moving out one probably would moving
move in so let's look at that so in the
cytosol the glycolysis pathway would
produce NADH the NADH would be now
converted to a form which can pass
through these transporters as it's a
mallet alpha-ketoglutarate transporter
NADH would be used to generate a mallet
now in the cytoplasm there is quite a
lot of oxaloacetate absolvo acetate
would be converted to the malate with
the help of enzyme malate dehydrogenase
now NADH would be utilized by that
enzyme to convert nad so the energy in
the NADH is actually converted in format
of Mellet now Malik would be transported
into the mitochondrial matrix via Malik
alpha-ketoglutarate antiporter and Malik
would be now inside the mitochondrial
matrix but still it does not give rise
to NADH at this point and NADH is the
form which could be utilizing electron
transport chain so malate is converted
back to a absolvo acetate with the help
of malate dehydrogenase and the miletti
hydrogen an enzyme can work in a
bi-directional fashion and the forward
and reverse reaction both are feasible
so the mallet and observe acetate are
interchangeable in forward and reverse
direction and when it converts Malik to
absolvo acetate it also regenerates NADH
which could be used in electron
transport chain but the harder component
of the Mellott alpha ketoglutarate and
DePorter is also key to blue to it so as
it's an antiporter alpha ketoglutarate
which is present in the mitochondrial
matrix would be transported out to the
cytosol now let's see how alpha
ketoglutarate comes back so alpha
ketoglutarate would eventually be
converted into glutamine
and in format of glutamate it can come
back into the mitochondria via the
glutamate aspartate and DePorter so
alpha-ketoglutarate
and gluten glutamate are also
interconvertible now the observer
acetate which was produced from malate
would be converted to actually aspartate
now aspartate can move out via the
glutamate aspartate antiporter and
absolvo acetate is converted into
exported by the reaction of
transamination right and now aspartate
can move out into the cytosol and on the
reverse process
buta bit can come in now the absolvo
acetate which is produced in this
process to regenerate NADH it can either
give rise to aspartate or it can go to
the TCA cycle to generate more energy
however the key event was to regenerate
in a NADH which was not present in the
mitochondria now NADH would give its
electron and the electron would move
along the electron transport chain which
would be accepted by a terminal acceptor
and ultimately it would pump hell out of
a proton into the mitochondrial inter
membrane space and using that proton
gradient lot of inert energy in terms of
ATP would be generated so the key goal
was to generate ATP and in order to
generate ATP via electron transport
chain and oxidative phosphorylation you
need NADH NADH is generated in the
glycolysis but cannot enter the
mitochondria because then in the inner
membrane is impermeable
so the overall Mallett aspartate shuttle
is a trick which mitochondria use to
transport
NADH from cytosol into the mitochondria
such that it can utilize in electron
transport chain that was all about this
at Miletus / trick shuttle I hope this
video was easy and understandable if you
liked this video give it a big thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you
you